we want to talk about showstopper that
is 90 year old burlesque dancer Dorothy
Williams on America's Got Talent last
night now more than 10 million Americans
tuned in to see her June that uh the
show was full of surprises and we were
backstage for it all that was a fun show
it was fun yeah yeah death-defying acts
amazing vocal performances I mean I am
so impressed so happy and we're not even
sure what to call this but this had to
be our favorite moment of the Nike
Entertainment Tonight I watched it all
the time at home
do you write do I love Entertainment
Tonight Dorothy made us believe dreams
really can come true all these years
later I've become a star at 90 it's it's
unbelievable but Simon talking about the
next big act in his life that really got
us how is your son Eric doing he's doing
amazing he's like two and a half years
old he loves music loves dancing he's
gonna follow me into why do I know that
oh you believe that on 2% record labels
watch out very ringing him up now gonna
work with my record label judge Mel B
was all about family to just hours
before her kids were doing their thing
in the car with her
is that regular for them well we do have
microphones in the car of course and
this is what happens on a lot of our car
journeys you know what this means you
have a future spice grow on your hands
there we go huh what do you think of
that hey we'll find out who moves on to
the next round tonight we're kind of
hoping tape base stays around are you
having the time of your life here whoo
you're on et what'd he make it up